The general good experience. Do you think you can still throw down,
like if it had to happen, like Jake, Paul called you out.
You probably me up. Really good boxer.
Good boxer. What if it was kickboxing? He does it.
Well, I know how to Kickbox younger, man. And I had good knees.
I could be kickboxing people,
but I could barely get through a workout without being in pain.
Now there's a reality of knees and backs.
Have you tried the PBC to peptide that too is also a good one. Yeah.
It helps you maintain,
but there's a big difference between maintaining and working out and then
getting, being able to train for a fight. Yeah.
So you think just being able to train for a fight, your body would break down.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Jake is interesting, man. He is excellent at truly brother.
His brothers. There's a, we played a video of his brother wrestling, uh, Paulo,
Kosta brother is legit. I think he's legit athlete.
I think he wrestled back in the day. Yeah. Yeah. He did wrestling college.
Jamie tried to shut it down. So it was like junior college.
That was actually a real college.
That's that Ohio rivalry right there. That's a dentist. No good.
Man. You gotta give credit where credit's due. I know those guys like to troll,
but he's Jake and his brother are both legitimate tough guys.
They're tough. Do you think that you need trolling now for fight sports?
Are we at a point where like, that's the only thing that engages the casual fan?
Well,
Khabib Nurmagomedov is the biggest draw in combat sports and he doesn't do
any trash talk.
But is that a reflection of dominance? It's like,
are we kind of watching to see if he'll lose? Like the Mayweather effect? Well,
like how many people are rooting for like,
Khabib seems like incredibly like sweet guy and he's like a consummate
professional,
but I feel like the way you market the fight is not in the way that when we were
younger watching Roy Jones where like Roy is going to do some crazy thing where
like put his hand behind his back and he just knocks a dude out.
Like we were rooting for Roy to win even his most dominant time.
I feel like now the way you promote the fight is, Oh,
this is the perfect guy to take out. Could be, you know,
like Justin's the perfect, Oh look. Yeah. You know, he's got striking,
but he has a wrestling background.
We're kind of like thinking of different ways we take them down. Whereas like,
yeah. I don't know. I don't know if like, I don't know if we're, if we're,
if we're rooting for him to win in that way. Um, well,
if you're a fan of his from the West shore and I'm sure if you're from Dagestan
yeah.
So you have a guy who's, uh,
could be a 28 or 29 and O and really a smashed everybody in front of them.
You always wonder, like,
who's going to be the guy that solves that riddle and Justin came real close
with those leg kicks. He was, he was really up his leg and,
but could be figured out a way to get the fight to the ground.
Almost finished it at the beginning or the end rather the first round and then
got him in the second round. He's just, he's on another level. Yeah.
And that's one of the things that happens when you're, I mean,
you gotta realize that guy is supremely disciplined. Primly dedicated,
like doesn't drink, doesn't smoke. Doesn't around doesn't abuse.
His body always fit, always in shape, always training and lives like a champion.
And it's like very religious, like very devout Muslim. Like doesn't,
doesn't suck. Oh yeah. He's so disciplined. No partying. He's not partying.
He's not doing Coke and banging hoes. He has none of that.
He's just smashing people, you know?
But I think he's there trying to talk him into having more fights. Right.
He told his mother that he was gonna retire after he kg. I remember seeing that,
but you know what, man,
he's in his prime and you only get one prime and you know,
and as little more can the most dominant man in the.
Yeah, what's going on here that way. Cut. He had there.
It was going around again from his last fight. Oh,
he always cuts a lot of weight, but it was apparently very brutal war. Yeah.
That's brutal. But one more throw. He's not really 155 pounds.
Th there's a thing in, in mixed martial arts that we all just accept. And it's,
it's sanctioned form of cheating. Like you're pretending you're 155 pounds.
So you draw your body out. You dry out to one 55 and then you balloon back up,
eat a lot of spaghetti and balloon back up to 200 pounds after the weight cut
that's nuts. Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Jerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.